the Joe Rogan experience dude I had Ari
Shaffir on my podcast one time and we
were at you ever you ever do a podcast
and above the Comedy Cellar they've got
a studio up no never
Bobby Kelly started it and it's us every
what it's called and um so I'm up there
doing my podcast with Ari and it's an
apartment it's like there's a there's a
bedroom and a bathroom and then the
studio and if we got to talking about
torture and I go I go you ever been
waterboarded he's like no I go this is a
bathroom right here I go you want you
want me to waterboard you and you know
our he's like yep sure let's do it or do
it so we go inside and I put a towel
over his face and he leans over
backwards and his head is below his body
in the shower stall the nozzle comes off
the wall and I spray down his face and
nothing nothing nothing and then all
sudden his body's convulsing his legs
are kicking he's [ __ ] screaming water
is shooting out of his nose he's choking
and it went on for like a couple minutes
and I'm [ __ ] dying and then he starts
laughing and we were just on the podcast
laughing without saying a word for
probably five minutes and then he goes
want me to do it to you I'm like [ __ ]
yeah and then II waterboarded me the
same thing happened Wow yeah the
waterboarding is legit yeah yeah yeah
yes so that's real torture yeah but it's
weird torture cuz you're not permanently
injuring someone like you think it
towards you think of like someone
cutting someone and lighting them on
fire [ __ ] like that
what's the torture you at least want to
be done to you it's good question
maybe that one maybe waterboarding I
don't know I get like electrocution they
electrocute you Ozark spoiler alert oh
yeah I don't say nothing wolf yeah I
think I think being made to be cold for
a long period I'm cold and nose they say
no sleep is actually the worst thing you
can do to somebody right like Chinese
water torture they just have the water
drip on you yeah yep
just keeps you awake true days trip yeah
that's a good tip if you ever fallen
asleep while you're driving folks get
if you stopped at a gas station and get
like a soda or a water and some ice and
then get like wet towel get a wet towel
with ice in it and just rub your face
cuz I used to smack myself in the face
when I was coming back from gigs yeah
and I'd be driving on the Mass Pike so
on the little stuff of the face just
sticking my head out the window you know
just trying to stay away yeah
[Applause]